in my ongoing quest to expose the
academics and other so-called experts
who specialize in the field of Muslim
Christian history and
interaction such as John Esposito and
Karen Armstrong let's take a quick look
at the 2018 book Crusade and Jihad the
Thousand-Year war between the Muslim
world and the global North by William R
pulk as we shall see it encapsulates all
the misrepresentations and errors of
history that have caused the West to
become utterly Clueless concerning the
roots of its conflict with Islam which
in turn leaves it utterly handicapped in
formulating a response to current
Islamic
threats for starters the book's title
and ambitious subtitle present it as a
comprehensive history the jacket cover
claims
that Crusade and Jihad is the first book
to Encompass in one volume the
entire pay attention the entire history
of the catastrophic encounter between
the global North and Muslim societies
William pul draws on more than half a
century of experience as a
historian to explain the Deep
hostilities between the Muslim world and
the global North and show how they grew
over the
centuries rather bizarrely however the
first thousand years of history in this
book are allotted a poultry 30 pages
even though the book is 550 pages long
it's quite the tome in other words a
mere 5% of the book deals with 10
centuries of conflict between the 8th
and 18th
century what could possibly explain this
lopsided approach after all that initial
Millennium contains all the seeds of
conflict as historian Franco cardini
wrote in his 1999 book Europe and Islam
quote if we ask ourselves how and when
the modern notion of Europe and the
European identity was born we realize
the extent to which Islam was a factor
albeit a negative one in its creation
repeated Muslim aggression against
Europe between the 7th and 8th centuries
then between the 14th and the 18th
centuries was a violent Midwife to
Europe while these vient midwives are
known today amongst historians as Arabs
Moes Turks berbers and tatars their
invasions and subsequent atrocities were
all conducted under the same jihadist
logic used by contemporary groups such
as Isis the Islamic State as infidels or
kufar Christian Europeans were free game
for rape enslavement and Slaughter as
Bernard Lewis said in his 1993 book
Islam and the West quote we tend
nowadays to forget that for
approximately a thousand years from the
Advent of Islam in the 7th Century until
the second Siege of Vienna in
1683 Christian Europe was under constant
threat from Islam the double threat of
conquest and conversion most of the the
new Muslim domains were rested from
Christendom Syria Palestine Egypt and
North Africa were all Christian nations
no less indeed rather more than Spain
and Sicily all this left a deep sense of
loss and a deep fear not only are these
formative centuries ignored in P's book
these 10 centuries essentially but what
he does present is often distorted in
Islam's favor again as his book's
succinct description explains pulk shows
how Islam arose and
Spread spread it didn't conquer across
North Africa into Europe climaxed in the
vibrant and sophisticated caliphate of
andalo in medieval Spain and was the
bright light in a European Dark
Age after effusively praising Islamic
Spain in his book pulk writes rather
disdainfully that the contrast between
Spain and the rest of Europe was
stunning few in Europe could read and
those few were H up in monasteries it is
hard to find evidence of more than a few
men or women of culture or even of a
degree of social refinement in lendalo
in contrast the Arts flourished new
forms of poetry were invented and
musical tastes
Advanced the problem here is not that
these descriptions are false but that
they are presented in a vacuum yes
Islamic Spain was very prosperous but as
with all premodern Islamic States it's
Prosperity was built almost entirely on
plundering its non-muslim neighbors of
their wealth and their bodies Cordoba
was a slave Emporium of European flesh
for centuries in his 1952 book the
history of Spain Lewis Bertrand a more
honest historian summarized what
Advanced sophisticated and prosperous L
andalo was doing to the Christians of
the north as follows to keep the
Christians of Northern Spain in their
place it did not suffice to surround
them with a zone of famine and
destruction
it was necessary also to go and swow
Terror and Massacre among them twice a
year in Spring and Autumn an army
sallied forth from Cordoba to go and
raid the Christians destroy their
Villages their fortified posts their
monasteries and their churches if one
bears in mind that this brigandage was
almost continual and that this Fury of
Destruction and and extermination was
regarded as a work of piety it was a
holy war Jihad against infidels it is
not surprising that whole regions of
Spain should have been made sterile
this was one of the capital causes of
the deforestation from which the
peninsula still suffers with what Savage
satisfaction and in and in what Pious
accents do the Arab chroniclers tell us
of those raids a typical phrase for
praising the devotion of a khif is this
quote he penetrated into Christian
territory where he wrought Devastation
devoted himself to pillage and took many
prisoners unquote the prolonged presence
of the Muslims therefore was a Calamity
for this unhappy country of Spain by
their system of continual rage they kept
her for centuries in a condition of
brigandage and
Devastation likewise pul fails to
mention that the stunning illiteracy of
Europeans was itself a byproduct of the
Jihad after the Muslim conquest of Egypt
around 641 Papyrus ceased to be imported
into Europe causing literacy rates to
drop back to pre-roman levels indeed
Christian Europe's Dark Ages came about
largely because Islam destroyed the
ancient Unity of the Mediterranean as
the eminent archaeologist Henry pin
demonstrated in his 1937 book Muhammad
and Charlemagne so there it is yet
another example of the fake history that
has long dominated the West's
understanding of its history with Islam
oh you may be wondering what the rest of
pok's book is all about the other 95%
it's more of the usual revisionist
history but in Reverse I'll explain in
another video down the line till then
bye